the eyes to the right 369
the nose to the left 126.
thank you
the eyes to the right
369
the nose to the left
126. so the eyes have it the eyes have
it unlocked
minister to move the motion relating to
the draft health and social care act
2008 regulated activities amendment
coronavirus number two regulations 2021
formally
the question is as on the order paper as
many as our that opinion say i
[Music]
the country no
division clear the lobby
okay just head there moving on to the
next vote which we'll concentrate on in
a few minutes time but let's digest what
has just happened the house of commons
has agreed by a large majority as you
can see a majority of 243 to introduce
covet status certification for venues
and large events but but but
there you can see the nose 126
mps voted against that motion now if
they are mainly conservatives we want to
know how many of them uh are
conservatives um that is quite a blow
for the prime minister as we're going to
analyze now with our deputy political
editor sam coates and sam we've just
seen an earlier vote haven't we uh on
the issue of um of wearing face masks in
in more venues and the government won
that but there was
41 41 mps voted against this is much
larger in terms of those saying no
yes uh the jump from 41 to 126
uh rebels uh we await to see
the breakdown to find out how many of
them are conservative there were
some
labour rebels it has to be said uh and
just on that any other party's saying
that they're going to vote against you
and you um the snp from libya weren't in
the chamber the liberal democrats were
voting against the vaccine passport uh
covert passports uh measures so there
are uh other factors at play but there
is going to have to have been quite a
substantial increase in the number of
tory rebels to get it up to
126. and so i think uh for all the talk
uh of the prime minister being able to
squeeze the
uh tory rebels in the last uh few hours
i think that uh it looks on first glance
as if there was um quite a big backlash
uh people doing what uh rebels such as
mark harper were suggesting during the
debate and essentially sending a signal
to the government that they cannot
simply proceed uh in the way that they
have
and i understand even in the last few
minutes boris johnson in the 1922
committee was telling
mps look if there have to be more votes
on covert
because we might have to do further
restrictions because frankly the level
of coronavirus is so incredibly high
then committing that there will be
perhaps even a recall of parliament
during the christmas recess
but none of that seemingly enough to
head off what looks like a very large
rebellion number